jacques c'est un plaisir de vous
recevoir sur ce plateau bonjour et bonne
année bonjour bonne année à vous aussi
bien sûr alors ça concerne bien sûr ce
que vous pensez de l'europe et le fait
qu'il soit encore là vingt ans plus tard
ne vous at il pas fait changer d'avis et
surtout qu'en est il aujourd'hui alors
non ça n'a pas fait changer d'avis mais
c'est vrai que l'euro a duré il a en
particulier traverser la crise de 2010 à
2013 il a survécu à la crise sanitaire
donc effectivement l'euro dur alors
c'est dû à plusieurs raisons il faut
quand même savoir que l'euro est la
seule institution réellement fédéral
dans l'union européenne et c'est
peut-être l'une des raisons qui
expliquent sa durée même si de un
certain nombre de pays de l'union
européenne n'ont toujours pas pris
l'euro et refusent de le prendre alors
c'est le cas de la suède de la pologne
de la roumanie donc effectivement il est
peut-être temps maintenant d'en tirer un
certain bilan jacques l'euro at il
provoque un qu'on le dit souvent une
forte inflation alors ça c'est je pense
une mauvaise critique qui est porté à
l'euro parce que si on regarde en
particulier les données qui sont
compilés par l'insee on voyait qu'il n'y
a pas eu d'effet d'inflation provoqué
par l'euro que ce soit par exemple sur
le revenu disponible où que ce soit sur
ce qu'on appelle plus spécifiquement le
revenu arbitrable c'est à dire le revenu
- les consommations contraintes et bien
il n'y a pas de montée des prix de 2002
à 2020 en tous les cas la hausse des
prix est beaucoup moins forte que celle
qui avait eu lieu deux 1981 à 2002 donc
on voit bien que de ce point de vue là
c'est pas le vrai problème maintenant il
faut savoir aussi une chose ce ne sont
que des moyennes et on sait que les gens
qui ont le revenu le plus fin d'une
grosse modo les 20% avec le revenu le
plus faible ne subissent par là même à
face une civile une inflation en fait
bien supérieurs à ceux qui gagnent le
plus d'argent au 20 pour cent le plus
riche pourquoi parce que les catégories
qui ont le revenu le plus fun consomme
évidemment surtout des produits
alimentaires
des biens de première nécessité alors
que les plus riches consomment des biens
qui sont beaucoup plus manufacturés en
particulier des biens électroniques dont
le prix a fortement baissé ces vingt
dernières années et donc effectivement
le ressenti de l'inflation n'est pas le
même suivant les catégories sociales de
la population auquel on s'adresse ça
veut dire quoi jacques leroy était en
dehors non l'euro n'a pas été indolore
malheureusement et on voit bien qu'il y
a un problème qui est extrêmement
important au niveau du commerce et que
c'était en fait la france avait de 1995
à 2002 une balance commerciale qui était
équilibré voire légèrement excédentaire
depuis 2002 le déficit commercial s'est
creusé pour quoi et bien parce que
l'euro abouti à une situation où
certains pays se voit surévaluées alors
c'est le cas de la france mais aussi de
l'italie de l'espagne et d'autres pays
se voit globalement sous-évalués même
parfois très massivement sous-évalué
pourquoi l'euro à bloquer les parités de
change au niveau de ce qu'elle était en
1999 or les taux de change les taux
d'inflation plutôt ont continué à
évoluer alors ils ont monté dans un
certain nombre de pays dont - monté dans
d'autres le résultat c'est justement
cette différence entre sous-évaluation
et surévaluation le fonds monétaire
international qui étudie ce genre de
question l'a d'ailleurs bien remarqué
dans toute une série de publications et
on voit que la france a maintenant une
économique est surévalué d'environ 10 à
14% l'allemagne est sous-évalué comme on
le voit d'ailleurs sur ce graphique
d'environ 10% il y a donc un écart
d'environ 25% entre la france et
l'allemagne et c'est ce qui explique le
bal dans l'énorme excédent commercial
que l'allemagne fait qu'ils montaient à
certains moments à 8% de son pib qui
était encore de pratiquement 7 % de son
pib en 2020 alors qu'on a compris à doha
des conséquences sur le commerce
extérieur et la richesse des français à
l'euro at il eu des conséquences là
dessus aussi oui effectivement amira et
ça c'est un point important alors il y
avait une étude ou qui a été fait en
2019 par le centre pour la politique
européenne qui travaillent à fribourg et
à berlin et qui avait calculé un petit
peu quels étaient les gagnants et
quelles étaient les perdants en fait de
l'euro et l'un de leurs calculs montré
que grosso modo par an les français
avaient perdu environ 3100 euros entre
1999 et 2010 est de 1100 euros c'est
quand même effectivement une grosses
sommes ça représente grosso modo deux
fois le pibe dans l'année mais par deux
fois le pipe deux fois le smic dans
l'année maintenant ces calculs ont donné
lieu à des discussions ils ont été
refaits en particulier dans mon
laboratoire on a refait les calculs on a
obtenu sur la période
1999 2018 une perte moyenne de revenus
d'environ 2600 euros parce que nous
n'avons pas pris les mêmes bases de
comparaison on a plutôt regardé comment
avait réagi les pays européens hors de
la zone euro par rapport aux pays
européens de la zone euro quand même ses
2600 euros il faut savoir que en 2018 et
c'est ce qu'on voit aussi sur ce
graphique et bien il ya une ouverture
des cours avec le temps qui est
extrêmement importante il ya en 2018
cela représentait 5800 euros autrement
dit pratiquement 5 fois le smic de
perdus par personne alors c'est très
important parce que on se souvient qu'en
2018 il ya eu aussi le mouvement décrit
les autres la base du mouvement de gilet
jaune c'est le problème du pouvoir
d'achat en réalité et puis si on regarde
par exemple dans cette campagne
présidentielle on a deux candidats pour
ne pas les nommer un madame valérie
pécresse et monsieur eric zemmour qui
font des acrobaties fiscale absolument
insensé pour arriver à redonner un mois
de smic à chaque français par an on voit
bien que là c'est le problème de l'euro
et je rappelle qu on a une différence
par rapport à notre situation
si nous n'avions pas eu l'euro 2
l'équivalent de 5 smic par an jacques
une telle perte de revenus
inévitablement ça va avoir des
conséquences en sur le chômage oui tout
à fait tout à fait à venir d'ailleurs
c'était en réalité le point sur lequel
on avait refait l'étude parce que un il
faut le dire j'avais fait une première
étude avec des collègues en 1900 en 2013
et là dans cette nouvelle étude on
s'étaient plutôt concentrées sur la
question du chômage alors nous avons
abouti sous l'hypothèse que la
productivité aurait été la même que ce
qu'elle a été dans la réalité nous avons
abouti à la conclusion qu'il y aurait eu
3 5 millions de personnes employées en
plus en 2019
c'est très important parce que c'est un
chiffre qu'il faut rapporter aux 6,1
millions de demandeurs d'emploi toutes
catégories de la halle à eux qui sont
calculées par pôle emploi autrement dit
que les demandeurs d'emploi n'aurait été
que 2,6 millions alors quand on après
quand on reprend la question entre
chômage et quasi chômage mais on aboutit
à une situation où de fait l'euro aurait
provoqué entre 45 et 50 % du niveau de
chômage tel qu'il était à la fin de 2019
alors jacques l'euro a donc provoqué un
des contraintes sur l'économie française
on a compris certaines mais ce qu' il
est devenu au fil du temps un concurrent
crédible en du dollar dans l'économie
mondiale eh bien non et bien non et ça
c'est aussi un point qui est extrêmement
important si vous voulez là encore il
faut prendre les statistiques du fonds
monétaire international qui calcule tous
les ans même tous les trimestres la part
des différentes monnaies dans les
réserves de change des banques centrales
et on voit que depuis 2008 où il était
monté à 27% c'était le maximum
historique de l'euro je rappelle par
comparaison que le dollar se situe entre
60 et 65 % des réserves internationales
l'euro a régulièrement baissé il se
trouve actuellement à 20% des réserves
internationales de change étant le prix
le plus intéressant est peut-être le
plus important c'est que la part de
l'euro aujourd'hui elle est d'un fériés
à la part cumulé du deutschemark du
français et du flore un hollandais avant
1999 autrement dit la part de l'euro
dans les réserves des banques centrales
n'atteint même pas le niveau de ce cas
tegner les monnaies des pays de la zone
euro avant la constitution de l'euro
dont jacques avec tout ça on en vient à
cette question alors pourquoi l'euro n'a
t-il pas disparu effectivement c'est la
question qu'on peut se poser alors je
pense qu'il ya deux réponses la première
réponse est une réponse essentiellement
politique l'euro je le rappelle c'est la
seule institution fédérale de l'union
européenne tant que les grands pays la
france l'allemagne l'italie n'auront pas
renoncer à l'illusion de construire une
union européenne fédérale eh bien ils ne
pourront pas se détacher de l'euro
qu'ils ne pourront pas prendre en compte
tous les défauts de l'euro ça c'est la
première raison il ya une deuxième
raison qui est plus conjoncturelle c'est
la politique de la banque centrale
européenne autant la banque centrale
européenne avait très mal réagi lors de
la crise des subprimes de 2008 à 2010
auto elle a très bien réagi avec la
crise sanitaire et de ce point de vue là
il est clair que ça a redonné une
certaine crédibilité
aujourd'hui à l'euro donc le problème
qui va se passer c'est quand la banque
centrale européenne va revenir
malheureusement parce qu'on sent bien
qu'il ya des pressions dans ce sens va
revenir à sa politique traditionnelle et
surtout à la vitesse à laquelle elle va
le faire c'est là que pourraient se
poser effectivement la question du
devenir de l'euro
merci à vous pour ce bilan des 20 ans de
l'euro merci pour cet édito économique
on se retrouve très prochainement oui
tout à fait merci puis surtout bonne
année merci vous aussi bonne année ira
mais apte et jacques
et sachez que cette nuit l'allemagne a
débranché 3